The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we'll
get started.
So today we are going to
dive into some parallel
architectures.
So the way, if you look at the
big world, is there's --
just counting parallelism, you
can do it implicitly, either
by hardware or the compiler.
So the user won't see it.
It will be done behind the
user's back, but can be done
by hardware or compiler.
Or explicitly, visible
to the user.
So the hardware part is done in
superscalar processors, and
all those things will have
explicitly parallel
architecture.
So what I am going to do is
spend some time just talking
about implicitly parallel
superscalar processors.
Because probably the entire time
you guys were born till
now, this has been the
mainstream, people are
building these things,
and we are use to it.
And now we are kind
of doing a switch.
Then we'll go into explicit
parallelism processors and
kind of look at different types
in there, and get a feel
for the big picture.
So let's start at implicitly
parallel superscalar
processors.
So there are two types of
superscalar processors.
One is what we call statically
scheduled.
Those are kind of simpler ones,
where you use compiler
techniques to figure out where
the parallelism is.
And what happens is the computer
keeps executing,
intead of one instruction at a
time, the few instructions
next to each other
in one bunch.
Like a bundle after
bundle type thing.
On the other hand, dynamically
scheduled processors --
things like the current Pentiums
-- are a lot more
complicated.
They have to extract instruction
level parallelism.
ILP doesn't mean integer linear
programming, it's
instruction level parallelism.
Schedule them as soon as
operands become available,
when the data is able to
run these instructions.
Then there's just a bunch of
things that get more about
parallelism, things like rename
registers to eliminate
some dependences.
You execute things
out of order.
If later instructions the
operands become available
early, you'll get those things
done instead of waiting.
You can speculate to execute.
I'll go through a little bit in
detail to kind of explain
what these things might be.
Why is this not going down.
Oops.
So if you look at a
normal pipeline.
So this is a 004
type pipeline.
What I have is a very
simplistic four
stage pipeline in there.
So a normal microprocessor,
a single-issue, will do
something like this.
And if you look at it, there's
still a little bit of
parallelism here.
Because you don't wait till the
first thing finishes to go
to the second thing.
If you look at a superscalar,
you have something like this.
This is an in-order
superscalar.
What happens is in every cycle
instead of doing one, you
fetch two, you decode two,
you execute two, and
so on and so forth.
In an out-of-order super-scalar,
these are not
going in these very
nice boundaries.
You have a fetch unit that
fetches like hundreds ahead,
and it keeps issuing as soon
as things are fetched and
decoded to the execute unit.
And it's a lot more of a complex
picture in there.
I'm not going to show too much
of the picture there, because
it's a very complicated thing.
So the first thing the processor
has to do is, it has
to look for true data
dependences.
True data dependence says that
this instruction in fact is
using something produced
by the previous guy.
So this is important because
if the two instructions are
data dependent, they cannot be
executed simultaneously.
You to wait till the first
guy finishes to
get the second guy.
It cannot be completely
overlapped, and you can't
execute them in out-of-order.
You have to make sure the
data comes in before you
actually use it.
In computer architecture jargon,
this is called a
pipeline hazard.
And this is called a
Read After Write
hazard, or RAW hazard.
What that means is that the
write has to finish before you
can do the read.
In a microprocessor, people try
very hard to minimize the
time you have to wait to do
that, and you really have to
honor that.
In hardware/software what you
have to do is you have to
preserve this program
ordering.
The program has to be executed
sequentially, determined by
the source program.
So if the source program says
some order of doing things,
you better --
if there's some reason for
doing that, you better
actually adhere to that order.
You can't go and just do things
in a haphazard way.
And dependences are basically
a fact of the
program, so what you got.
If you're lucky you'll get a
program without too many
dependences, but most probably
you'll get programs that have
a lot of dependences.
That's normal.
There's a lot of importance
of the data dependence.
It indicates the possibility
of these hazards, how these
dependences have to work.
And it determines the order in
which the results might be
calculated, because if you need
the result of that to do
the next, you have what you
call a dependency chain.
And you have to excute
that in that order.
And because of the dependency
chain, it sets an upper bound
of how much parallelism that
can be possibly expected.
If you can say in all your
program there's nothing
dependent -- every instruction
just can go any time --
then you can say the best
computer will get done in one
cycle, because everything
can run.
But if you say the next
instruction is dependent on
the previous one, the next
the previous one, you
have a chain.
And no matter how good the
hardware, you have to wait
till that chain finishes.
And you don't get that
much parallelism.
So the goal is to exploit
parallelism by preserving the
program order where it affects
the outcome of the program.
So if we want to have a look and
feel like the program is
run on a nice single-issue
machine that does one
instruction after another after
another, that's the
world we are looking in.
And then we are doing all this
underneath to kind of get
performance, but give
that abstraction.
So there are other dependences
that we can do better.
There are two types of
name dependences.
That means there's no real
program use of data, but there
are limited resources
in the program.
And you have resource
contentions.
So the two types of resources
are registers and memory.
So linear resource
contentions.
The first name dependence is
what we call anti-dependence.
Anti-dependence means that --
what I need to do is, I want
to write this register.
But in the previous instruction
I'm actually
reading the register.
Because I'm writing the
next one, I'm not
really using the value.
But I cannot write it until
I have read that value.
Because the minute I write it,
I lose the previous value.
And if I haven't used
it, I'm out of luck.
So there might be a case that
I have a register, that I'm
reading the register and
rewriting it some new value.
But I have to wait till the
reading is done before I do
this new write.
And that's called
anti-dependence.
So what that means is we have
to wait to run this
instruction until this is
all -- you can't do
it all before that.
So this is called a Write After
Read, as I said, in the
architecture jargon.
The other dependences have
what you call output
dependence.
Two guys are writing
the register, and
then I'm reading it.
So I want to read the value
the last guy wrote.
So if I reorder that,
I get a wrong value.
Actually you can even
do better in here.
How can you do better in here?
AUDIENCE: You can eliminate I.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You can elimiate the first one,
because nobody's using
that value.
So you can go even further
and further, but
this is also a hazard.
This is called a Write
After Write hazard.
And the interesting thing is
by doing what you call
register renaming, you can
eliminate these things.
So why do both have to use
the same register?
In these two, if I use a
different register I don't
have that dependency.
And so a lot of times in
software, and also in modern
superscalar hardware, there's
this huge amount of hardware
resources that actually
do register renaming.
So they realized that
anti-dependence is output
dependent, and said
-- "Wait minute.
Why do I even have to do that?
I can use a different
register." So even
though you have --
Intel basically [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
accessory only have
eight registers.
They are about 100
registers behind.
Hardware registers just
basically let you do this
reordering and renaming
-- register renaming.
So the other type of depencence
is control
dependence.
So what that means is if you
have a program like this, you
have to preserve the
program ordering.
And what that means is S1 is
control dependent on p1.
Because depending on what p1 is,
it will depend on this one
to get excuted.
S2 is control dependent
on p2, but not p1.
So it doesn't matter what p1
does, S2 will execute only if
p2 is true.
So there's a control dependence
in there.
Another interesting thing is
control dependence may -- you
don't need to preserve
it all the time.
You might be able to do things
out of this order.
Basically, what you can do is if
you are willing to do more
work, you can say -- "Well,
I will do this.
I don't know that I really need
it, because I don't know
whether the p2 is true or not.
But I'll just keep doing it.
And then if I really wanted,
I'll actually have the results
ready for me." And that's called
speculative execution.
So you can do speculation.
You speculatively think
that you will need
something, and go do it.
Speculation provides you with
a lot of increased ILP,
because it can overcome
control dependence by
executing through branches,
before even you know where the
branch is going.
And a lot of times you can go
through both directions, and
say -- "Wait a minute, I don't
know which way I'm going.
I'll do both sides." And I know
at least one side you are
going, and that will
be useful.
And you can go more and more,
and soon you see that you are
doing so much more work than
actually will be useful.
So the first level of
speculation is -- speculation
basically says, you go, you
fetch, issue, and execute
everything.
You do the end of the thing
without just committing your
weight into the commit to make
sure that the right thing
actually happened.
So this is the full
speculation.
There's a little bit of less
speculation called dynamic
scheduling.
If you look at a microprocessor,
one of the
biggest problems is the pipeline
stall is a branch.
You can't keep even a pipeline
going, even in a single-issue
machine, if there's a branch,
because the branch condition
gets resolved.
Not after the next instruction
has to get fetched.
So if you do a normal thing,
you just have to
reinstall the pipeline.
So what dynamic scheduling or
a branch predictor sometimes
does is, it will say I
will predict where
the branch is going.
So I might not have fed board
direction, but I will
speculatively go fetch down
one path, because it looks
like it which it's going.
For many times, like for example
in a loop, 99% of the
time you are going in the
backage, because you don't go
through that.
And then if you predict
that you are mostly
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
So the branch predictors are
pretty good at finding these
kind of cases.
There are very few branches
that are kind of 50-50.
Most branches have
a preferred path.
If you find the preferred path
you can go through that, and
you don't pay any penalty.
The penalty is if you made a
mistake, you had to kind of
back up a few times.
So you can at least do
in one direction.
Most hardware do that, even the
simplest things do that.
But if you do good speculation
you go both.
You say -- "Eh, there's a chance
if I go down that path
I'm going to lose a lot.
So I'll do that, too." So that
does a lot of expensive stuff.
And basically this is more
for data flow model.
So as soon as data get available
you don't think too
much about control, you
keep firing that.
So today's superscalar
processors have huge amount of
speculation.
You speculate on everything.
Branch prediction.
You assume all the branches,
multilevel down you predict,
and go that.
Value prediction.
You look at it and say -- "Hey,
I think it's going to be
two." And in fact there's a
paper that says about 80% of
program values are zero.
And then you say -- "OK.
I'll think it's zero,
and it'll go on.
And if it is not zero, I'll
have to come back and do
that." So things like that.
AUDIENCE: Do you know what
percentage of the time it has
to go back?
PROFESSOR: A lot of times I
think it is probably an 80-20
type thing, but if you do too
much you're always backing up.
But you can at least do
a few things down
assuming it's zero.
So things like that.
People, try to take advantage
of the statistical nature of
programs. And you are
mining every day.
So basically there's no --
it's almost at the entropy.
So every information is kind
of taken advantage in the
program, but what that means
is you are wasting a lot of
time cycles.
So the conventional
wisdom was --
"You have Moore's slope.
You keep getting these
transistors.
There's nothing to do with it,
so let me do more other work.
We'll predicate, we'll do
additional work, we'll go
through multipe branches, we'll
assume things are zero.
Because what's wasted?
Because it's extra work, if it
is wrong we just give it up."
So that's the way it went, and
the thing is it's very
inefficient.
Because a lot of times you are
doing -- think about even a
simple cache.
If you have 4-way as a cache.
Every cycle when you're doing
a memory fetch, you are
fetching on all four, assuming
one of it will have hit.
Even if you have a cache hit
where only one bank is hit,
and all the other three
banks are not hit.
So you are just doing a
lot more extra work
just to get one thing.
Of course because if you wait to
figure out which bank, it's
going to add a little
bit more delay.
So you won't do it parallelly.
You know that's it's going to
be one of the lines, so you
just go fetch everything
and then later decide
which one you want.
So things like that really
waste energy.
And what has been happening in
the last 10 years is you
double the amount of
transistors, and you add 5%
more performance gain.
Because statistically you have
mined most of the lower
hanging fruit, there's
nothing much left.
So you're getting to a point
that has a little bit of a
statistical significance,
and you go after that.
So of course, most of
the time it's wrong.
So this leads to this chart that
actually yesterday I also
pointed out.
So you are going from hot plate
to nuclear reactor, to
rocket nozzle.
We tend to be going
in that direction.
That is the path, because we
are just doing all these
wasteful things.
And right now, the power
consumption on processors is
significant enough in both
things like laptops --
because the battery's not
getting faster -- as well as
things like Google.
So doing this extra
useless work is
actually starting to impact.
So for example, if you look
at something like Pentium.
You have 11 stages
of instructions.
You can execute 3 x86
instructions per cycle.
So you're doing this huge
superscalar thing, but
something that had been creeping
in lately is also
some amount of explicit
parallelism.
So they introduced things like
MMX and SSE instructions.
They are explicit parallelism,
visible to the user.
So it's not hiding trying
to get parallelism.
So we have been slowly moving to
this kind of model, saying
if you want performance you have
to do something manual.
So people who really cared
about performance had
to deal with that.
And of course, we put multiple
chips together to build a
multiprocessor --
it's not in a single chip --
that actually do parallel
processing.
So for about three, four years
if you buy a workstation it
had two processors
sitting in there.
So dual processor, quad
processor machines came about,
and people started using that.
So it's not like we are doing
this shift abruptly, we have
been going that direction.
For people who really cared
about performance, actually
had to deal with that and were
actually using that.
OK.
So let's switch gears a little
bit and do explicit
parallelism.
So this is kind of
where we are --
where we are today, where
we are switching.
So basically, these are the
machines that parallelism
exposed to software --
either compiler.
So you might not see it as a
user, but it exposes some
layer of software.
And there are many different
forms of it.
From very loosely coupled
multiprocessors sitting on a
board, or even sitting on
multipe machines -- things
like a cluster of
workstations --
to very tightly coupled
machines.
So we'll go through, and figure
out what are all the
flavors of these things.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
PROFESSOR: Mhmm?
AUDIENCE: So does it mean that
since there being the level
parallelism, the processor can
exploit the fact that the
compiler knows the higher
level instructions?
Does that make any difference?
PROFESSOR: It goes both ways.
So what the processor knows is
it know values for everything.
So it has full exact knowledge
of what's going on.
Compiler is an abstraction.
In that sense, processor
wins in those.
On the other hand, compile
time doesn't
affect the run time.
So the compiler has a much
bigger view of the world.
Even the most aggressive
processor can't look ahead
more than 100 instructions.
On the other hand, the compiler
sees ahead of
millions of instructions.
And so the compiler has the
ability to kind of get the big
picture and do things --
global kind of things.
But on the other hand, it loses
out when it doesn't have
information.
Whereas when you do the hardware
parallelism, you have
full information.
AUDIENCE: You don't have
to give up one at
the loss of the other.
PROFESSOR: The thing is, I don't
think we have a good way
of combining both very well.
Because the thing is, sometimes
global optimization
needs local information,
and that's not
available at run time.
And global optimization is very
costly, so you can't say
-- "OK, I'm going to do it any
time." So I think it's kind of
even hybrid things.
There's no nice mesh in there.
So if you think a little bit
about parallelism, one
interesting thing is
this Little's Law.
Little's Law says parallelism
is a multiplication of
throughput vs. latency.
So the way to think about that
is the parallelism is dictated
by the program in some sense.
The program has a certain
amount of parallelism.
So if you have a thing that has
a lot of latency to get to
the result, what that means is
there's a certain amount of
throughput you can satisfy.
Whereas if you have a thing that
has a very low latency
operation, you can
go much wider.
So if you look at Intel
processors, what they have
done is the superscalars --
they have actually, to get
things faster they have a very
long latency.
Because they know they
couldn't go more than
three or four wide.
So they went like 55 the
pipeline, three wide.
Because you can go fast,
so they assume the
parallelism fits here.
So still you need a lot
of parallelism.
So you say -- "Three, why
should [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
issue machine.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] three it's no
big deal." But no, if you have
55 the pipeline you need to have
165 parallel instructions
on the fly any given time.
So that's the thing.
Even in the moder machine,
there's about hundreds of
instruction on the
fly, because the
pipeline is so large.
So if you said 3-issue,
it's not that.
I mean this happens in there.
So this gives designers a lot
of flexibiilty in where you
are expanding.
And in some ways you
can have a lot --
there are some machines that
are a lot wider, but the
latency is --
For example, if you look
at an Itanium.
It's clock cycle is about half
the time of the Pentium,
because it has a lot less
latency but a lot wider.
So you can do these
kind of tradeoffs.
Types of parallelism.
There are four categorizations
here.
So one categorization is,
you have pipeline.
You do the same thing in
a pipeline fashion.
So you do the same
instruction.
You do a little bit, and you
start another copy of another
copy of another copy.
So you kind of pipeline the
same thing down here.
Kind of a vector machine --
we'll go through categories
that kind of fit in here.
Another category is data-level
parallelism.
What that means is, in a given
cycle you do the same thing
many many many many --
the same instructions for
many many things.
And then next cycle
you do something
different, stuff like that.
Thread-level parallelism breaks
in the other way.
Thread-level parallelism
says --
"I am not connecting the cycles,
they are independent.
Each thread can go do something
different."
And instruction-level
parallelism is kind of a
combination.
What you are doing is, you are
doing cycle by cycle -- they
are connected -- and each cycle
you do some kind of a
combination of operations.
So if you look at
this closely.
So pipelining hits here.
Data parallel execution,
things like SIMD
execution hits here.
Thread-level parallelism.
Instruction-level parallelism.
So before a models of
parallelism, what software
people see kind of fits also in
this architecture picture.
So when you are designing a
parallel machine, what do you
have to worry about?
The first thing is
communication.
That's the begin --
the problem in here.
How do parallel operations
communicate the data results?
Because it's not only an
issue of bandwith,
it's an issue of latency.
The thing about bandwith is that
had been increasing by
Moore's Law.
Latency, speed of light.
So as I pointed out, there's
no Moore's Law on speed of
light, and you have
to deal with that.
Synchronization.
So when people do different
things, how do you synchronize
at some point?
Because you can't keep going
on different paths, at some
point you have to
come together.
What's the cost?
What are the processes
of going it?
Some stuff it's very
explicit --
you have to deal with that.
Some machines it's built in,
so every cycle you are
synchronizing.
So sometimes it makes it easier
for you, sometimes it
makes it more inefficient.
So you have to figure
out what is in here.
Resource management.
The thing about parallelism is
you have a lot of things going
on, and managing that is
a very important issue.
Because sometimes if you put
things in the wrong place, the
cost of doing that might
be much higher.
That really reduces the
benefit of doing that.
And finally the scalability.
How do you build process
that not only can do 2x
parallelism, but can
do thousand?
How can you keep growing
with Moore's Law.
So there are some ways you can
get really good numbers, small
numbers, but as you go bigger
and bigger you can't scale.
So here's a classic
classification of parallel machines.
This has been [? divided ?]
up by Mike Flynn in 1966.
So he came up with four ways
of classifying a machine.
First he looked at how
instruction and data is issued.
So one thing is single
instruction, single data.
So there's single instruction
given each cycle, and it
affects single data.
This is your conventional
uniprocessor.
Then came a SIMD machine
-- single
instruction, multiple data.
So what that means is the given
instruction affects
multiple data in here.
So things like -- there are two
types, distributed memory
and shared memory.
I'll go to this distinction
later.
So there are a bunch
of machines.
In the good old times this was
a useful trick, because the
sequencer -- or what ran the
instructions -- was a pretty
substantial piece of hardware.
So you build one of them and
use it for many, many data.
Even today data in a Pentium
if you are doing a SIMD
instruction, you just issue one
instruction, it affects
multiple data, and you
can get a nice reuse
of instruction decoding.
Reduce the instruction bandwidth
by doing SIMD.
Then you go to MIMD,
which is Multiple
Instruction, Multiple Data.
So we have multiple instruction
streams each
affecting its own data.
So each data streams,
instruction streams
separately.
So things like message passing
machines, coherent and
non-coherent shared memory.
I'll go into details
of coherence and
non-coherence later.
There are multiple categories
within that too.
And then finally, there's kind
of a misnomer, MISD.
There hasn't been a
single machine.
It doesn't make sense to have
multiple instructions work on
single data.
So this classification,
right now -- question?
AUDIENCE: I've heard
that [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Multiple instruction,
single data?
I don't know.
You can try to fit something
there just to have something,
but it doesn't fit really well
into this kind of thinking.
So I don't like that thinking.
I was thinking how should I do
it, so I came up with a new
way of classifying.
So what my classification
is, what's the last
thing you are sharing?
Because when you are running
something, if it is some
single machine, some thing has
to be shared, and some things
have to be separated.
So are you sharing instructions,
are you sharing
the sequencer, are you sharing
the memory, are you sharing
the network?
So this kind of fits many things
nicely into this model.
So let's go through
this model and see
different things in there.
So let's look at shared
instruction processors.
So there had been a lot of work
in the good old days.
Did anybody know Goodyear
actually made supercomputers?
Not only did they make tires,
for a long time they were
actually making processors.
GE made processors,
stuff like that.
And so a long time ago this
was a very interesting
proposition, because there was a
huge amount of hardware that
has to be dedicated to doing the
sequence and running the
instruction.
So just to share that was a
really interesting concept.
So people built machines
that basically --
single instruction
stream affecting
multiple data in there.
I think very well-known machines
are things like
Thinking Machines CM-1,
Maspar MP-1 --
which had 16,000 processors.
Small processors --
4-bit processors, you can only
do 4-bit computation.
And then every cycle you can
do 16,000 of them, 4-bit
things in here.
It really fits in to the kind of
things they could build in
hardware those days.
And there's one controller
in there.
So it is just a neat thing,
because you can do a lot of
work if you actually can
match it in that form.
So the way you look at that is,
to run this array you have
this array controller.
And then you have processing
elements, a
huge amount of them.
And you have each processor
mainly had distributed memory
-- each has its own memory.
And so given instruction,
everybody did the same thing
to memory or arithmetic
in there.
And then you had also
interconnect network, so you
can actually send it.
A lot of these things have
the [? near-enabled ?]
communication.
You can send data you near
enable, so everybody kind of
shifts the 2-D or some kind
of torus mapping in there.
And if you can program that,
you can get really good
performance in there.
And each cycle, it's
very synchronous.
So each cycle everybody does
the same thing -- go to the
next thing, do the same thing.
So the next very interesting
machine is this Cray-1.
I think this is one of
the first successful
supercomputers out there.
So here's the Cray-1, it is this
kind of round seat type
thing sitting in here.
Everybody know what was
under the seat?
AUDIENCE: Cooling.
PROFESSOR: Cooling.
So here's a photo.
I don't think you can see that
-- you can probably look at it
when I put this on the
web -- was this
entire cooling mechanism.
In fact Seymour Cray at one
time said one of his most
important innovations
in this machine is
how to cool the thing.
And this is a generation,
again, that
power was a big thing.
So each of these columns had
this huge amount of boards
going, and in the middle had
all the wiring going.
So we had this huge mess of
wiring in the middle --
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
-- and then you had all
these boards in
there in each of these.
So this is the Cray-1
processor.
AUDIENCE: Do you know
your little --
your laptop is way faster
than that Cray --
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Did you have the clock
speed in here?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: 80 MHz.
PROFESSOR: So, yeah.
And that cost like $10 million
or something like
that at that time.
Moore's Law, it's
just amazing.
If you think if you apply
Moore's Law to any other thing
we have, it can't do
the comparison.
We are very fortunate to be
part of that generation.
AUDIENCE: But did it
have PowerPoint?
PROFESSOR: So what it had,
was it had these
three type of registers.
It had scalar registers,
address
registers, and vector registers.
The key thing there is
the vector register.
So if you want to do
things fast --
no, fast is not the word.
You can do a lot of computation
in a short amount
of time by using the
vector registers.
So the way to look at that is
normally when you go to the
execute stage you
do one thing.
In a vector register what
happens is it got pipelined.
So execute state happened one
word next, next, next.
You can do up to 64
or even bigger.
I think it was 64 length,
length 64 things.
So you can -- so that
instruction.
So you do a few of these, and
then this state keeps going on
and on and on, for 64.
And then you can pipeline in
the way that you can start
another one.
Actually, this will use the same
executioner, so you have
to wait till that finishes
to start.
So you can pipeline to get a
huge amount of things going
through the pipeline.
And so each cycle you can
graduate many, many
things going on.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask you
a quick question?
Something I'm trying to get
straight in my head.
My notion -- and I don't think
I'm right on this, that's why
I'm asking you -- is machines
like the Cray, I know you were
talking about some of the vector
operations, those were
by and large a relatively
small set of operations.
Like dot products, and
vector time scalar.
On the other hand, when you
look at the SIMD machines,
they had a much richer
set of operations.
PROFESSOR: I think with
scatter-gather and things like
conditional execution, I think
vector machines could be a
fairly large --
I mean it's painful.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The SIMD instruction
is Pentium.
I think that is mainly targeting
single processing
type stuff.
They don't have real
scatter-gather.
AUDIENCE: And the
Cell processor?
PROFESSOR: Cell is distributed
memory.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but on one
the -- what do they
call them, the --
PROFESSOR: I don't think you
can scatter-gather either.
It's just basically, you have
to align words in, word out.
IBM is always about
doing align.
So in even AltiVec, you can't
even do unaligned access.
You had to do aligned access.
So if there is no run align,
you had to pay a
big penalty in there.
So if you look at how
this happens.
So you have this entire
pipeline thing.
When things get started the
first value is at this point
done in one clock cycle.
The next value is halfway
through that.
Another value is in
some part of a --
is also pipelined, the
alias pipeline.
And other values are kind of
feeding nicely into that.
So if you have one -- this
is called one lane.
You can have multiple lanes,
and then what you can do is
each cycle you get 40
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
And the next ones are in
the middle of that,
next ones are in middle.
So what you have is a very
pipelined machine, so you can
kind of pipeline things
in there.
So you can have either one
lane, or multiple lanes
pipeline coming out.
So if you look at the
architecture, what you had is
you have some kind of vector
registers feeding into these
kind of functional units.
So at a given time, in this one
you might be able to get
eight results out, because
everything gets pipelined.
But the same thing is
happening in there.
Clear how vector
machines work?
So it's not really parallelism,
it's basically --
especially if you are one --
it's a superpipelined thing.
But given one instruction, it
will crank out many, many,
many things for that
instruction.
And doing parallelism is easy in
here too, because it's the
same thing happening to very
regular data sets.
So there's no notion of
asynchronizations and all
these weird things.
It's just a very
simple pattern.
So the next thing is the shared
sequencer processor.
So here it's similar to the
vector machines because each
cycle you issue a single
instruction.
But the instruction is
a wide instruction.
It had multiple operations in
these same instructions.
So what it says is --
"I have multiple execution
units, I have memory in a
separate unit, and each
instruction I will tell each
unit what to do." And so
something you might have --
two integer units, two
memory/load store units, two
floating-point units.
Each cycle you tell each
of them what to do.
So you just kind of keep issuing
an instruction that
affects many of them.
So sometimes what happens is if
this has latency of four,
you might have to wait till this
is done to do the next
instruction.
So if one guy takes long,
everybody has to kind
of wait till that.
So it's very synchronous
going.
So things like synchronization
stuff were
not an issue in here.
So if you look at a pipeline,
this is what happens.
So you have this instruction.
It's an instruction, but
you are fetching a wide
instruction.
You are not researching
a simple instruction.
You decode the entire thing,
but you can decode it
separately.
And then you go execute on
each execution unit.
One interesting problem
here was this
was not really scalable.
What happened here is each
functional unit, if you had
one single register file, has
to access the register file.
So each function would say --
"I am using register R1," "I
am using R3," "I am using R5."
So what has to happen is the
register file has to have --
basically, if you have eight
functional units, 16 outports
and 8 inports coming in.
And then of course, when you
build a register file it has a
scale, so it had huge
scalability issues.
So it's a quadratically scalable
register function.
Question?
AUDIENCE: The sequencer
[INAUDIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It's basically you had to wait
till everybody's done, there's
nothing going out
of any order.
And memory also.
Since everybody's going to
memory, this is not scalable.
So people try to build -- you
can do four, eight wide, but
beyond that this register and
memory interconnect became a
big mess to build.
And so one kind of modification
thing people did
was called Clustered VLIW.
So what happens is you have a
very wide instruction in here.
It goes to not one cluster,
but different clusters.
Each cluster has its own
register file, its own kind of
memory interconnect
going on there.
And what that means is if you
want to do intercluster
communication, you have to
go to a very special
communication network.
So you don't have this bandwidth
expansion register.
So you only have, we'll say two
execution units, so you
only have to have four
out and one in to the
register filing cycle.
And then if you want other
communication, you have a much
lower bandwidth interconnect
that you'll have
to go through that.
So what this does is you kind
of expose more complexity to
the compiler and software, and
the rationale here is most
programs have locality.
It's like everybody always wants
to to communicate with
everybody else, so there are
some locality in here.
So you can basically cluster
things that are local together
and put it in here, and then
when other things have to be
communicated you can use this
communication and go about
doing that.
So this is kind of the state of
the art in this technology.
And something like --
what I didn't put --
Itanium kind of fits in here.
Itanium processor.
So then we go to
shared network.
There has been a lot
of work in here.
People have been building
multiprocessors for a long
time, because it's a very
easy thing to build.
So what you do is --
if you look at it, you have a
processor unit that connects
its own memory.
And it's like a multiple
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Then it has a very tightly
connected network interface
that goes to interconnect
network.
So we can even think about a
workstation farm as this type
of a machine.
But of course, the network is a
pretty slow one that requres
an ethernet connector.
But people build things
that have much
faster networks in there.
This was designed in a way you
can build hundreds and
thousands of these things --
nodes in here.
So today if you look at the
top 500 supercomputers, a
bunch of them fits into this
category because it's very
easy to scale and build
very large.
AUDIENCE: Are you doing
SMPs in this list,
or some other place?
PROFESSOR: SMP is mostly shared
memory, so shared network.
I'll do shared memory next.
But there are problems
with it.
All the data layout has to be
handled by software, or by the
programmer basically.
If you want something outside
your memory, you had to do
very explicit communication.
Not only you, the other guy who
has the data actually has
to cooperate to send
it to you.
And he needs to know that
now you have the data.
All of that management
is your problem.
And that makes programming
these kind of things very
difficult, which you'll probably
figure out by the
time you're done with Cell.
So Cell has a lot of
these issues, too.
The problem here is not dealing
with most of the data,
but the kind of corner
cases that you don't
know about that much.
There's no nice safe way, of
saying -- "I don't know where,
who's going to access it.
I'll let the hardware take
care of it." There's no
hardware, you have to
take of it yourself.
And also message passing has
a very high overhead.
Most of the time in order to do
message, you have to invoke
some kind of a kernel thing.
You have to actually do a kernel
switch that will call
the network --
it's operaing system involves a
process, basically, to get a
message in there.
And also when you get a message
out you have to do
some kind of interrupt or
polling, and that's a bunch of
copies out of kernel.
And this became a pretty
expensive proposition.
So you can't send messages the
size of one [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
so you had to accumulate a huge
amount of things to send
out to amortize the cost
of doing that.
Sending can be somewhat
cheap, but receiving
is a lot more expensive.
Because receiving you
have to multiplex.
You have no idea who
it's coming to.
So you have to receive, you
have to figure out who is
supposed to get it.
Especially if you are running
multiple applications, it
might be for someone's
application.
You had to contact
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So it's a big mess.
That is where people went to
shared memory processors,
because it became easier
message method to use.
So that is basically the SMPs
Alan was talking about.
The nice thing is it will work
with any data placement.
It might work very slowly, but
at least it will work.
So it makes it very easy to take
your existing application
and first getting it working,
because it's
just working there.
You can choose to optimize
only critical sections.
You can say -- "OK,
this section I
know it's very important.
I will do the right thing,
I will place it properly
everything." And the rest of it
I can just leave alone, and
it will go and get the
data and do it right.
You can run sequentially, of
course, but at least the
memory part I don't have
to deal with it.
If some other memory just once
in a while accesses that data
that you have actually
parallelized, it
will actually work.
So you only have to worry about
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
that you are parallelizing.
And you can communicate using
load store instructions.
You don't have to get always
in order to do that.
And it's a lot lower overhead.
So 5 to 10 cycles, instead of
hundreds to thousands cycles
to do that.
And most of these messages
actually stoplight some
instructions to do this
communication very fast.
There's a thing called fetch&op,
and a thing called
load linked/store conditional
operations.
There are these very special
operations where if you are
waiting for somebody else, you
can do it very fast. So if two
people are communicating.
So people came up with these
very fast operations that are
low cost, as a last --
if the data's available it
will happen very fast.
Synchronization.
And when you are starting to
build a large system, you can
actually give a logically shared
view of memory, but the
underlying hardware can be
still distributed memory.
So there's a thing called --
I will get into when you
do synchronization --
directory-based cache
coherence.
So you give a nice, simple
view of memory.
But of course memory is
really disbributed.
So that kind of gives the
best of both worlds.
So you can keep scaling and
build large machines, but the
view is a very simple
view of machines.
So there are two categories
in here.
One is non-cache coherent, and
then hardware cache coherence.
So non-cache coherence kind of
gives a view of memory as a
single address space.
But you had to deal with that if
you write something to get
there early to me, you had
to explicitly say --
"Now send it to that person."
But we're still in a single
address space.
It doesn't give the
full benefits of a
shared memory machine.
It's kind of inbetween
distributed memory.
In distributed memory basically
everybody's in a
different address space,
so you had to map
by sending a message.
Here, you just say I have
to flush and send it
to the other guy.
Some of the early machines, as
well as some big machines,
were no hardware cache
coherence.
Things like supercomputers were
built in this way because
it's very easy to build.
And the nice thing here is if
you know your applications
well, if you are running good
parallel large applications,
and you are actually knowing
what the communication
patterns are -- you can
actually do it.
And you don't have to pay the
hardware overhead to have this
nice hardware support
in there.
However, a lot of small scale
machines -- for example, most
people's workstations are
stuffy, it's probably now two
Pentium Quad machines --
actually add memory.
Because if you are trying to
do the starting things it's
much easier to do
shared memory.
And also it's easier to bulid
small shared memory machines.
And people talk about using a
bus-based machine, and also
using a large scale
directory-based machine in here.
So for bus-based machines, how
do you do shared memory?
So there's a protocol, what we
call a snoopy cache protocol.
What that means is, every time
you modify your location
somewhere -- so of course you
have that in your cache --
you tell everybody in the world
who's using a busing, "I
modified that." And then if
somebody else also has that
memory location.
That person says, "Oops, he
modified it." Either he
invalidates it or gets
the modified copy.
If you are using something new,
you have to go and snoop.
And you can ask everybody and
say -- "Wait a minute, does
anybody have a copy of this?"
And some more complicated
protocols have saying -- "I
don't have any, I have a copy
but it's only read-only.
So I'm just reading it, I'm
not modifying it." Then
multiple people can have the
same copy, because everybody's
reading and it's OK.
And then there's the next thing
-- "OK, I am actually
trying to modify this thing."
And then only I
can have the copy.
So some data you can give to
multiple people as a read
copy, and then when you are
trying to write everybody gets
disinvited, only the person
who has write
has access to it.
And there are a lot of
complicated protocols how if
you write it, and then somebody
else wants to write
it, how do you get
to that person?
And of course you have to keep
it consistent with memory.
So there is a lot of work in
how to get these things all
working, but that's the
kind of basic idea.
So directory-based machines
are very different.
In directory-based machines
mainly there's a
notion of a home node.
So everybody has local space in
memory, you keep some part
of your memory.
And of course you have
a cache also.
So you have a notion that this
memory belongs to you.
And every time I want to do
something with that memory I
had to ask you.
I had to get your permission.
"I want that memory, can
you give it to me?"
And so there are two things.
That person has a directory
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] say -- "OK,
this memory is in me.
I am the one who right now owns
it, and I have the copy."
Or it will say --
"You want to copy that memory
to this other guy to write,
and here is that person's
address or that machine's
name." Or if multiple people
have taken this copy and are
reading it.
So when somebody asks
me for a copy --
assume you ask to
read this copy.
And if I have given it to nobody
to read, or if I have
given it to other people
to read, so I say --
"OK, here's a copy.
Go read." And I add that person
is reading that, and I
keep that in my directory.
Or if somebody's writing that.
I say sure, "I can't give it
to read because somebody's
writing that." So I
can do two things.
I can tell that person,
saying --
"You have to get it from the
person who's writing.
So go directly get
it from there.
And I will mark that now you own
it as a read value." Or, I
can tell the person
who's writing --
"Look, you have to give up
your write privilege.
If you have modified it, give
me the data back." And that
person goes back to
the read or no
privileges with that data.
When I get that data, I'll
send it back to this
person and say --
"Here, you can read." And the
same thing if you ask for
write permission.
If anybody has [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
I have to tell everybody --
"Now you can't read
it anymore.
Go invalidate, because
somebody's about to write."
Get the invalidate request
coming back, and then when
you've done that I say, "OK,
you can write that." So
everybody keeps part of
the memory, and then
all of that in there.
So because of that you can
really scale this thing.
So if you look at a
bus-based machine.
This is the kind of
way it looks like.
You have a cache in here,
microprocessor, central
memory, and you have
a bus in here.
And a lot of small machines,
including most people's
desktops, basically fit
in this category.
And you have a snoopy
bus in here.
So a little bit of
a bigger machine,
something like a Sun Starfire.
Basically it had four processors
in the board, four
caches, and had an interconnect
that actually has
multiple buses going.
So it can actually get a little
bit of scalability,
because here's the bottleneck.
The bus becomes the
bottleneck.
Everybody has to go
through the bus.
And so you actually get
multiple buses to get
bottleneck, and it actually had
some distributed memory
going through a crossbar here.
So this cache coherent
protocol has
to deal with that.
And going to the other extreme,
something like SGI Origin.
In this machine there are two
processors, and it had
actually a little bit of
processors and a lot of memory
dealing with the directory.
So you keep the data, and you
actually keep all the
directory information
in there --
in this.
And then it goes --
then after that it almost uses
a normal message passing type
network to communicate
with that.
And they use the crane to
connect networks, so we can
have a very large machine
built out of that.
So now let's switch to
multicore processors.
If you look at the way we have
been dealing with VLSI, every
generation we are getting more
and more transistors.
So at the beginning when you
have enough transistors to
deal with, people actually start
dealing with bit-level
parallelism.
So you didn't have -- you can
do 16-bit, 32-bit machines.
You can do wider machines,
because you have enough
transistors.
Because at the beginning you
have like 8-bit processors,
16-bit, 32-bit.
And then at some point that I
have still more transistors, I
start doing instruction-level
parallelism in a die.
So even in a bit-level
parallelism, in order to get
64-bit you had to actually
have multiple chips.
So in this regime in order to
get parallelism, you need to
have multiple processors --
multiprocessors.
So in the good old days you
actually built a processsor,
things like a minicomputer.
Basically you had one
processor dealing
with a 1-bit slice.
So in the 4-bit slice, dealing
with that amount, you could
fit in a chip.
And a multichip made
a single processor.
Here a multichip made
a multiprocessor.
We are hitting a regime
where a multichip --
what [? it ?] will be
multiprocessor -- now fits in
one piece of silicon, because
you have more transistors.
So we are going into a time
where multicore is basically
multiple processors
on a die --
on a chip.
So I showed this slide.
We are getting there, and it's
getting pretty fast. You had
something like this, and
suddenly we accelerated.
We added more and more
cores on a die.
So I categorized multicores
also the way I categorized
them previously.
There are shared memory
multicores.
Here are some examples.
Then there are shared
network multicores.
Cell processor is one,
and at MIT we are
building also Raw processor.
And there is another part, what
they call crippled or
mini-cores.
So the reason in this graph you
can have 512, is because
it's not Pentium sized things
sitting in there.
You are putting very simple
small cores, and a
huge amount of them.
So for some class replication,
that's also useful.
So if you look at shared memory
multicores, basically
this is an evolution path
for current processors.
So if you look at it, what they
did was they took their
years' worth of and billions
of dollars worth of
engineering building a single
superscalar processor.
Then they slapped a few of them
on the same die, and said
-- "Hey, we've got a multicore."
And of course they
were always doing shared memory
at the network level.
They said -- "OK, I'll put the
shared memory bus also into
the same die, and I got a
multicore." So this is
basically what all these
things are all about.
So this is kind of gluing these
things together, it's a
first generation.
However, you didn't build a core
completely from scratch.
You just kind of integrated what
we had in multiple chips
into one chip, and basically
got that.
So to go a little bit beyond,
I think you can do better.
So for example, this
AMD multicore.
Basically you have CPUs in
there, actually have a full
snoopy controller in there,
and can have some other
interface with that.
So you can actually start
building more and more uni
CPU, thinking that you're
building a multicore.
Instead of saying, "I had this
thing in my shelf, I'm going
to plop it here, and then
kind of [INAUDIBLE]
And you'll see, I
think, a lot of
interesting things happening.
Because now as they're connected
closely in the same
die, you can do more things than
what you could do in a
multiprocessor.
So in the last lecture we talked
a little bit about what
the future could be in
this kind of regime.
Come on.
OK.
So one thing we have been doing
at MIT for -- now this
practice is ended, we started
about eight years ago -- is to
figure out when you have all the
silicon, how can you build
a multicore if you to
start from scratch.
So we built this Raw processor
where each --
we have 16, these small cores,
identical ones in here.
And the interesting thing is
what we said was, we have all
this bandwidth.
It's not just going from pins
to memory, we have all this
bandwidth sitting next
to each other.
So can we really take advantage
of that to do a lot
of communication?
And also the other thing is that
to build something like a
bus, you need a lot
of long wires.
And it's really hard to
build long wires.
So in Raw processor it's
something like each chip, a
large amount of part, is into
this eight 32-bit buses.
So you have a huge amount
of communication
next to each other.
And we don't have any kind of
global memory because that
requires, right now, either do
a directory, which you didn't
want to build, or have a bus,
which will require long wires.
So we did in a way that all
wires -- no wires longer than
one of the cores.
So we can do short wires, but
we came up with a lot of
communications for each of
these, what we called tile
those days, are very
tightly coupled.
So this is kind of a direction
where people perhaps might go,
because now we have all this
bandwidth in here.
And how would you take advantage
of that bandwidth?
So this is a different way
of looking at that.
And in some sense the Cell fits
somewhere in this regime.
Because what Cell did was
instead of -- it says, "I'm
not building a bus,
I am actually
building a ring network.
I'm keeping distributed memory,
and provide to Cell a
ring." I'm not going to go
through Cell, because actually
you had a full lecture the day
before yesterday on this.
AUDIENCE: Saman, can I
ask you a question?
Is there a conclusion that I
should be reaching in that I
look at the multicores you can
buy today are still by and
large two and four processors.
There are people that
have done more.
The Verano has 16 and
the Dell has 8.
And the conclusion that I want
to reach is that as an
engineering tradeoff, if you
throw away the shared memory
you can add processors.
Is that a straightforward
tradeoff?
PROFESSOR: I don't think
it's a shared memory.
You can still have things
like directory-based
cache coherent things.
What's missing right now is what
people have done is just
basically took parts in their
shelves, and kind of put it
into the chip.
If you look at it, if you put
two chips next to each other
on a board, there's a certain
amount of communication
bandwidth going here.
And if you put those things
into the same die, there's
about five orders of magnitude
possibility to communicate.
We haven't figured out how to
take advantage of that.
In some sense, we can almost say
I want to copy the entire
cache from this machine to
another machine in the cycle.
I don't think you even would
want to do that, but you can
have that level of huge amount
of communication.
We are still kind of doing
this evolutionary path in
there [UNINTELLIGIBLE] but I
don't think we know what cool
things we can do with that.
There's a lot of opportunity
in that in some sense.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because the
interesting thing is --
the way I would say it is,
in the good old days
parallelization sometimes
was a scary prospect.
Because the minute you
distribute data, if you don't
do it right it's a lot slower
than sequential execution.
Because your access time becomes
so large, and you're
basically dead in water.
In this kind of machine
you don't have to.
There's so much bandwidth
in here.
Latency was still -- latency
would be better than going to
the outside memory.
And we don't know how
to take advantage of
that bandwidth yet.
And my feeling is as we go about
trying to rebuild from
scratch multicore processors,
we'll try to figure out
different ways.
So for example, people are
coming up with much more rich
semantics for speculation and
stuff like that, and we can
take advantage of that.
So I think there's a lot of
interesting hardware,
microprocessor, and then kind
of programming research now.
Because I don't think anybody
had anything in there saying ,
"Here's how we would take it
down to this bandwidth." I
think that'll happen.
Now the next [? thing ?]
is these mini-cores.
So for example, this PicoChip
has array of
322 processing elements.
They have 16-bit RISC, so
it's not even a 32-bit.
Piddling little things,
3-way issue in.
And they had like
240 standard --
basically, nothing
more than just a
multiplier, and add in there.
64 memory tiles, full control,
and 14 some special
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] function
accelerator.
So this is kind of what people
call heterogeneous systems.
Where what this is -- you have
all these cores, why do you
make everything the same?
I can make something that's good
doing graphics, something
that's good doing networking.
So I can kind of customize
in these things.
Because what we have in
excess is silicon.
We don't have power in excess.
So in the future you can't
assume everything is working
all the time, because
that will still
create too much heat.
So you kind of say -- the best
efficiencies, for each type of
computation you have some few
special purpose units.
So we kind of say if I'm doing
graphics, I fit to my graphics
optimized code.
So I will do that.
And the minute I want to do a
little bit of arithmetic I'll
switch to that.
And sometimes I am doing TCP,
I'll switch to my TCP offload.
Stuff like that.
Can you do some kind
of mixed in there?
The problem there is you need to
understand what the mix is.
So we need to have a good
understanding of
what that mix is.
The advantage is it will be a
lot more memory efficient.
So this is kind of going
in that direction.
And so in some sense, if you
want to communicate you have
these special communication
elements.
You have to go through that.
And the processor can do some
work, and there are some
memory elements.
So far and so forth.
So that's one push, people are
pushing more for embedded very
low power in.
AUDIENCE: Is this starting to
look more and more like FPGA,
which is [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's a
kind of a combination.
Because the thing about FPGA is,
it's just done 1-bit lot.
That doesn't make sense
to do any arithmetic.
So this is saying -- "Ok,
instead of 1 bit I am doing 16
bits." Because then I can
very efficiently build
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Because I don't have to
build [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
out of scratch.
So I think that an interesting
convergence is happening.
Because what happened, I think,
for a long time was
things like architecture and
programming languages, and
stuff like that, kind of
got stuck in a rut.
Because things there are
so very efficiently and
incremental -- it's like doing
research in airplanes.
Things are so efficient,
so complex.
Here AeroAstro can't build an
airplane, because it's a $9
billion job to build a good
airplane in there.
And it became like that.
Universities could not build
it because if you want to
build a superscalar it's,
again, a $9 billion type
endeavor to do that -- thousands
of people, was very,
very customized.
But now it's kind of hitting
the end of the road.
Everbody's going back and saying
-- "Jeez, what's the
new thing?" And I think there's
a lot of opportunity
to kind of figure out is there
some radically different thing
you can do.
So this is what I have
for my first lecture.
Some conclusions basically.
I think for a lot of people who
are programmers, there was
a time that you never cared
about what's under the hood.
You knew it was going to
go fast, and in the
air it will go faster.
I think that's kind of
coming to an end.
And there's a lot of
variations/choices in
hardware, and I think software
people should understand and
know what they can
choose in here.
And many have performance
implications.
And if you know these things you
will be able to get high
performance of software
built easy.
You can't do high performance
software without knowing what
it's running on.
However, there's a
note of caution.
If you become too much attached
to your hardware, we
go back to the old days of
assembly language programming.
So you say -- "I got every
performance out of a -- now
the Cell says you have seven
SPEs." So in two years, they
come with 16 SPEs.
And what's going to happen?
Your thing is still working on
seven SPEs very well, but it
might not work on 16 SPEs,
even with that.
But of course, you really
customize for Cell too.
And I guarantee it will not
run good with the Intel --
probably Quad, Xeon processor
-- because it will be doing
something very different.
And so there's this tension
that's coming back again.
How to do something that is
general, portable, malleable,
and at the same time get good
performance with hardware
being exposed.
I don't think there's
an answer for that.
And in this class we are going
to go to one extreme.
We are going to go low level
and really understand the
hardware, and take advantage
of that.
But at some point we have to
probably come out of that and
figure out how to be,
again, high level.
And I think that these
are open questions.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
thoughts, and this may be
unanswerable, but how could
Cell really [INAUDIBLE].
And not Cell only, but some of
these other ones that are out
there today, given how hard
they are to program.
PROFESSOR: So I have
this talk that I'm
giving at all the places.
I said the third software
crisis is due
to multicore menace.
I termed it a menace, because it
will create this thing that
people will have to change.
Something has to change,
something has to give.
I don't know who's
going to give.
Either people will say -- "This
is too complicated, I am
happy with the current
performance.
I will live for the next 20
years at today's level of
performance." I doubt
that will happen.
The other end is saying --
"Jeez, you know I am going to
learn parallel programming, and
I will deal with locks and
semaphores, and all
those things.
And I am going to jump in
there." That's not going to
happen either.
So there has to be something
in the middle.
And the neat thing is,
I don't think anybody
knows what it is.
Being in industry, it makes them
terrified, because they
have no idea what's happening.
But in a university,
it's a fun time.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Good question.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So we'll take about a five
minutes break, and switch
gears into concurrent
programming.